in this video I want to familiarize you
with the idea of a limit which is a
super important idea it's really the
idea that all of calculus is based upon
but despite being so super important
it's actually a really really really
really simple idea so let me draw a
function here actually let me define a
function here a kind of a simple
function so let's define f of X let's
say that f of X is going to be X minus 1
over X minus 1 and you might say hey Sal
look I have the same thing in the
numerator in the denominator if I have
something divided by itself that would
just be equal to 1 can't I just simplify
this to f of X equals 1 and I would say
well you're almost true the difference
between f of X equals 1 and this thing
right over here is that this thing can
never eat this thing is undefined when X
is equal to 1 because if you set let me
define it right let me write it over
here if you have F of sorry not F of 0
if you have F of 1 what happens in the
numerator you get 1 minus 1 which is let
me just write it down in the numerator
you get 0 and then the denominator you
get 1 minus 1 which is also 0 and so
anything divided by 0 we're including 0
divided by 0 this is undefined this is
undefined so you can make the
simplification you can say that this is
you can say that this is the same thing
as f of X is equal to 1 but you would
have to add the constraint that X cannot
X cannot be equal to 1 now this and this
are equivalent both of these are going
to be equal to 1 for all other X's other
than 1 but at x equals 1 it becomes
undefined this is undefined and this
one's undefined so how would i graph
this function so let me graph it so that
is my y is equal to f of x axis y is
equal to f of x axis and then this over
here is my x axis x axis
and then let's say that this is the
point X is equal to one this over here
would be X is equal to X is equal to
negative one this is y is equal to one
right up there I could do negative one
with that matter much relative to this
function right over here and let me
graph it so it's essentially for any X's
for any X other than one f of X is going
to be equal to one so it's going to be
look like this it's going to look like
this except at one at one f of X is
undefined so I'm going to put a little
bit of a gap right over here the circle
to signify that this function is not
defined we don't know what this function
equals at one we never defined it this
definition of the function doesn't tell
us what to do with one it's literally
undefined literally undefined when x is
equal to one so this is this is the
function right over here and so once
again if someone were to ask you what is
f of one you'd go see it and let's say
that even if this was a function
definition you would go KX is equal to
108 there's a gap in my function over
here it is undefined so let me write it
again I'm that's why it's kind of
redundant but I'll rewrite it F of one
is undefined but whatever what if I were
to ask you what is the function
approaching as x equals one and now this
is starting to touch on the idea of a
limit so as X gets closer and closer to
one so as we get closer and closer X's
to one as we get closer and closer X's
to one what is the function approaching
well this entire time the function
what's it getting closer and closer to
on the left-hand side no matter how
close you get to one as long as you're
not at one you're actually at f of X is
equal to one over here from the right
hand side you get the same thing so you
could say and you'll will get more and
more familiar with this idea as we do
more examples that the limit as X and L
I am short for limit as X approaches 1
as X approaches 1 of f of X of f of X
is equal to as we get closer we can get
unbelievably we can get infinitely close
to one as long as we're not at one and
our function is going to be equal to one
it's getting closer and closer and
closer to one it's actually at one the
entire time so in this say k case we
could say the limit as X approaches 1 of
f of X is 1 so once again has very fancy
notation we're just saying look what is
the function approaching as X gets
closer and closer to 1 let me do another
example where we're dealing with a curve
just so that you have the general idea
so let's say let's say that I have the
function f of X let me just just for the
sake of variety let me call it G of X
let's say that we have G of X is equal
to I could define it this way we could
define it as x squared when when X does
not equal
I don't know when X does not equal 2 and
let's say that when x equals 2
when x equals 2 it is equal to 1 so once
again it kind of an interesting function
that as you'll see is is not fully
continuous it has a discontinuity so let
me graph it so this is my y equals f of
X axis this is my x axis right over here
let me draw x equals 2x let's say this
is x equals 1 this is x equals 2 this is
negative 1 this is negative 2 and then
let me draw so everywhere everywhere
except x equals 2 it's equal to x
squared so let me draw it like this
so it's going to be a parabola look
something like this it's going to look
something let me draw a better version
of the parabola so it'll look something
like this
it looks something like this not the
most beautifully drawn parabola in the
history of drawing parabolas but I think
it'll give give you the idea I think you
know the parabola looks like hopefully
it's a would other way it should be
symmetric it let me draw a redraw it
because that's kind of ugly okay
me and that's looking better okay all
right there you go all right now this is
this would be the graph of just x
squared but this can't be it's not x
squared when X is equal to two so once
again once again when X is equal to two
we should have a little bit of a
discontinuity here so I'll draw a gap
right over there because when x equals
two the function is equal to 1 when X is
equal to 2 so let's say that and I'm not
doing them on the same scale but let's
say that so this on X on the graph of f
of X is equal to x squared this would be
4 this would be 2 this would be 1 this
would be 3 so when X is equal to 2 our
function is equal to 1 so when X is
equal to 2 our function is equal to is
equal to 1 so there's a bit of a bizarre
function but we can define it this way
you can define a function however you
like to define it and so notice it's
just like the graph of x of x of f of X
is equal to x squared except when you
get to 2 it has this gap because that's
you don't use the f of X is equal to x
squared when X is when X is equal to 2
you use f of X or I should say G of X
you use G of X is equal to 1 have I been
saying f of X I apologize for that you
use G of X is equal to 1 so then the
then at 2 we just set to just exactly at
2 it drops down to 1 and then it keeps
going along the function G of X is equal
to or I should say along the function x
squared so my question to you so there's
a couple of things if I were to just
evaluate the function G of 2 while you
look at this definition okay when x
equals 2 I use this situation right over
here and it tells me it's going to be
equal to 1 let me ask a more interesting
question or perhaps a more interesting
question what is the limit as X
approaches 2 of G of X of G of X once
again fancy notation but it's asking
something pretty pretty pretty simple
it's saying as X gets closer and closer
to 2 as you get closer and closer and
this isn't a rigorous definition we'll
do that in future videos as X gets
closer and closer to 2 what
is G of X approaching so if you get to
one point nine and then one point nine
nine nine and then one point nine nine
nine nine nine nine and then one point
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine what
is G of X approaching and or if you were
to go from the from the positive
direction if you were to say two point
one what's G of two point one what's G
of two point oh one what's G of two
point zero zero one
what is that approaching as we get
closer and closer to it and you can see
it visually just by drawing the graph as
G gets closer and closer to two and if
we were to follow it along the graph we
see that we are approaching four even
though that's not where the function is
the function drops down to one the limit
of G of X as X approaches two is equal
is equal to four and you can even do
this numerically using a calculator and
let me let me do that
because I think that will be interesting
so let me get a calculator out let me
get my trusty my trusty ti-85 out let me
so here is my calculator and you could
numerically say okay what's it going to
approach as you approach x equals two so
let's try 1.9 4 for X is equal to one
point nine you would use this top Clause
right over here so you'd have one point
nine squared and so you'd get three
point six one well what if you get even
closer to two so one point nine nine and
once again let me square that well now
I'm at three point nine six but what if
I do one point nine nine nine nine nine
nine and I square that and I square that
I'm going to get three point nine nine
six notice I'm going in closer and
closer and closer to our point and if I
did if I got really close one point nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine squared what am I going to get to
it I'm it's not actually going to be
exactly for this calculator just rounded
things up it's going to get to a number
really really really really really
really really close to four and we can
do something from the positive direction
too and it actually has to be the same
number when we approach from the from
the below what we're trying to approach
and above what we're trying to approach
so if we try to point one squared
we get 4.4 if we do to point let me go a
couple of steps ahead to point oh wow so
this is much closer to 2 now squared now
we're getting much closer to 4 so the
closer we get to 2 the closer it seems
like we're getting to 4 so once again
that's a numeric way of seeing that the
limit as X approaches 2 from either
direction of G of X even though right at
2 the function is equal to 1 because
it's discontinuous the limit as we're
approaching 2 we're getting closer and
closer and closer to 4